hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website.com today we're going to be
going over the second part in the series
of the Kings gambit opening so we're
going to go ahead and get started here
white opens up on to e4 black responds
pawn to e5 and why it offers up a pawn
sacrifice onto f4 and black accepts and
as we talked about last time we're going
to be focusing on the knight to f3
variation in the last video we touched
on if pawn tries to come down to g5 and
today we're actually going to be looking
at some other variations one of the most
common openings you'll see for black in
this case is a move that Fischer used he
actually wrote a little book on it
called a bus to the Kings gambit and as
just a simple move on to d6 and one of
the big things this does as you see it
cuts off this g4 square that eventually
white would want to get his Queen to so
no worries we are going to just avoid
this we're not going to attack
immediately instead we're just going to
go ahead and build up our development
here so first thing we're just going to
do is develop Knight to c3 normal
development move in the King's gambit
you may see something from black
developing as well Knight to f6 why it's
going to continue on to d4 you may see
black
come here obviously he'll eventually
want to castle he may bring his Bishop
to e7 we're going to bring our Bishop
getting him into the action to Bishop to
c4 a lot of times black will go ahead
and Castle and why it's going to go
ahead and castle and this is the
position that I really want to touch on
right now because this position for
white is one that you're going to see
over and over and over it doesn't really
matter what black plays a lot of times
eventually in a lot of games you play in
the King's game you're going to come
this position and I want to touch on a
few things one we have great Center
control we have our two pawns here on d4
and e4 and we have control over all of
the center square so we have our bishop
nicely positioned here attacking the f7
square we have both of our Knights
developed we have already castled and
the good thing that we talked about in
the first video which still applies here
is although black is up a piece in
material this pawn right here we can
pretty much take this at any time we
like with our bishop and we also have
this F file open for our rook and the
one good thing about rooks as many of
you may know is you want them to be on
open files if they're on the back and
they're not doing much it's really not
going to help your chess game a lot you
want to get them on open files and you
want to connect them so
next couple moves I can take this pawn I
can move my queen up connect these rooks
and my gameplay is going to be very good
from here there's a lot of different
things you can do with this but keep in
mind even from this position you are
down upon but you have much better
development you have great center
control and from here you should have a
pretty good game now obviously there are
a few other things that black can do and
we'll go ahead and touch on those a lot
of times they won't know Fisher's moving
so they may just do a development move
maybe a Knight to f6 as their second
move and we're going to go ahead and do
the same thing we're going to develop
obviously they're attacking our pawns
we're going to go ahead and defend if
they decide to develop their other
pieces well we're going to go ahead and
do the same thing advance our pawn to d4
and depending on which move they do they
may bring their Bishop down attacking
that is completely fine we can if we
want go ahead and take this pawn back we
can come out here put our bishop on c4
really whatever we like we can also come
up here and start moving and attacking
their Knights to get them out of the way
eventually as you'll see you may easily
get back to the position that we just
talked about so we are going to go back
and look at one more another thing
you'll see you'll see them develop from
the other side and in this case we're
actually not going to move the pawn
first I mean excuse me the knight first
because we don't need to defend this
we're first going to just move the pawn
up and that is obviously putting more
focus on the center and so depending on
what he does next if he brings his
knight out we can always develop our
knight next
it this is a great move because if now
he decides to play something like pawn
to d6 we can we have a little more
options we can continue development with
her our knight we can try to push his
Knight out of the way we can bring the
bishop out we can go ahead and capture
the pawn here so experiment a little bit
there's obviously a lot of options with
these but hope this has given you a
little more insight as to the variations
of the King's game pin how to play then
so I hope you enjoyed make sure you
subscribe to the videos keep checking
back I should be having a lot more
videos up in the near future and be sure
to check out the website it is WWH s
website comm and that's going to be
launching very soon and gonna have a lot
of great material so thanks again for
watching and I'll see you guys later